la familia de estos ex militares asegura
que se fueron haití engañados esto es
posible según su experiencia militar
estas personas podrían haber sido
engañadas
raúl buenas noches si es posible se dan
muchos casos en el mundo entero en donde
contratistas que no mercenarios terminan
finalmente convertidos en escenarios
debido a triquiñuelas o diferentes
tretas que emplean grupos de poder o
gobiernos para utilizarlos en con sus
objetivos en el caso de ati en donde hay
una situación política lo acabamos de
ver sumamente complicada una situación
social y económica también muy crítica
pues ya se ha confirmado en colombia que
varios de estos militares retirados
fueron contratados legal y legítimamente
para prestar servicios de seguridad como
contratistas inclusive contratados por
el mismo gobierno según anunció uno de
los senadores de la oposición pero
posteriormente se da el hecho del
asesinato y no hay claridad exactamente
si los colombianos participaron
directamente en esto o si fueron
víctimas de propiciatorias de una trampa
o si evidentemente alguno de ellos
participó de manera directa en el
asesinato del presidente las
declaraciones
recoge inclusive telesur de la esposa en
miami dice que no fueron colombianos los
asesinos de su presidente pero que
fueron mercenarios los únicos
extranjeros que en ese momento estaban
allí pues serán los colombianos aunque
llegaron un poco tarde de modo que la
situación como todo magnicidio en la
historia es sumamente confusa hay muchas
cortinas de humo y hay un entramado
político y económico muy fuerte detrás
que va a ser difícil de desenmarañar
quién pudiera entonces estar detrás de
este asesinato del presidente de moix
pues viene el embajador haitiano en
colombia de unas declaraciones hace poco
planteando más presiones internas
políticas ligadas con corrupción muy
fuertes que podrían ser los que
motivaron podría ser estamos en el campo
de las especulaciones los que motivaron
esto lo cierto del caso es que la
inestabilidad política de haití es muy
grande y ahí hay una fuerte influencia
del narcotráfico
el contrabando de la ilegalidad dadas
las circunstancias de pobreza y de
perturbación social y de inseguridad que
se dan en el país